Richard Dolan is one of the world's most
lauded UFO researchers and historians
firstly you said around 1962 there was
an explosion of nuclear bombs off the
coast of Hawaii
and I think it was 36 nuclear bombs and
there was a UFO there that got shot down
if I heard correctly
can you explain what happened
yeah that was part of something known as
operation Dominic from I think 1945 till
the
1998 end of the 20th century
the World experience I think 2050
nuclear detonations second to last
Dominic uh detonation and this man saw
and
the UFO like zumbai and presumably he
thought it was it went into the ocean
he learned later he's doing cross-train
with radar operators later that day and
he
in the scuttlebutt learned that they
were tracking UFO they track UFOs he
said all the time during detonation